non-minimalists
i've completely minimized my life i
accept
my boyfriend i haven't minimized him in
any kind of way
so i guess i should first state that
he's perfect otherwise because i know
you're going to tell me that i can't
change people around me but i can change
people around me
he likes to pile up dishes at the sink
in the sink all around the house and i
had an epiphany today
that what if i just box up my entire
kitchen and just leave him one plate
you know one set of utensils you know
coffee mug
that can be used for juice and coffee
and take all that stuff with me
when i leave for work next week and just
kind of see how that
holds up so i guess i'm just asking for
some advice
on living with someone who can't seem to
put anything away and just has no plans
to do that but
other than that they are perfect
speaking of passive aggressive behavior
i mean i aaron i actually respect that
you're trying to do something yes you're
right so we've got this little line it's
it goes up you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you yeah
meaning you can't yeah force someone to
change
yeah but you can surround yourself with
people with similar values etc right
right now here's the thing like you got
to ask yourself
this is really we were talking about
cost of admission earlier but this is
her cost of admission i agree a hundred
percent
yeah you know i makes me laugh when
you get married or you move in with
somebody and then you try to change them
no
hey you bought this ticket this is what
comes with the ticket
yeah there's nobody perfect so you can't
marry somebody or move in with them and
then be like hey
so i'm gonna change this about you no no
no you knew this was the deal
yeah like this was there are certain
things about my wife about all of our
partners
you don't love but i can't that's who
she is
so i gotta take there's nobody perfect
no i can't tinker
until i find perfection is never gonna
happen right no
if you don't if that's the only problem
i think you
made out pretty good yeah they're
perfect
otherwise yeah that sounds pretty
perfect yeah
like all you gotta do is dishes like
yeah listen erin wash a dish
well you know what's interesting like
i'm kidding
no i mean you know with like uh mariah
and i my wife and i uh
like she does the dishes and like it's
it's it's great like i really appreciate
it but there are some times where she's
like hey look if you got one dish
like just don't leave it in the sink go
ahead and do it so there are certain
things that she asks to me that i'm
willing to sacrifice
and when i'm willing to sacrifice stuff
for her she's willing to sacrifice stuff
for me and that's what a relationship
is so the question aaron is like you
know are what are you sacrificing for
him
and can you go to him and say hey look
like for this to really work
better like i really love to sacrifice
this for you do you mind doing x y and z
for me and
maybe you can get the conversation
started there but yeah i totally agree
like if he was always piling up dishes
you can't just expect
that he's not gonna do that um no but
you can't have a conversation yes
you can tell them how important it is
and not in a way here's the thing we
wanna we wanna avoid three things we
wanna
avoid blaming and shaming and i think i
think
passive aggressive action for sure
yeah yeah and instead and also like name
naming like name calling
right so that can be passive aggressive
way or that can just be aggressive right
depending on how you handle it and so
i think that's often the problem here is
what what happens is intellectual
we know this isn't on par with what we
want and so but we react emotionally
i can't believe you you're just gonna
leave those dishes in the sink like that
yeah
yeah and it's like well maybe there's a
better way hey
can i talk to you about this look i know
i've got a little bit of ocd
and i don't like having dishes in this
thing would you five words would always
help me would you be willing to yeah
would you be willing to do the dishes
after
we're done eating dude totally what
you're gonna say no i hate you that's
exactly you that's exactly what mariah
she only
had to ask me like one time or say
something like that one time she was
like basically
talking about how she felt disrespected
if i just left like one dish in the sink
and i was like oh i didn't realize i was
making you feel disrespected so that was
but she didn't come to me and be like
really what what the heck's your problem
dude yeah like you're a freaking slob
what is it i mean like if she would
approach me that way i probably would
not have
yeah exactly do you know both beth and i
had dishpiling tendencies
and so i told her i go hey here's what
we're gonna do for a week
paper plates yeah do you like eating on
paper plates
and she and plastic forks and everything
so everything we just picked and threw
away she was like i don't
this makes me feel like a child i'm like
then we gotta we gotta do better yeah
together we gotta do better because i'm
just as bad and if there's a period
where like
you know you're like we both get in
those head spaces where we know
that might pile up in the in the pileup
headspace
and she said she'll say let's go paper
this week dude together we got to do
better yeah
so that's how aaron has to approach us
with her partner well that's maybe
so for what she and i have been trying
to do together
it works better if i go hey let's do
this together yeah of course
i'll i'll wash them up you dry them off
and that way even if they're my dishes
or even if they're her dishes or
whatever they are
they're our dishes we live in the place
together yeah but there are
there are things about like i said there
are things about beth that i just
uh shh i'm not gonna say any because i
know she's gonna listen to this but
but but they're they're but but that but
i have said to her
i know this is part of who you are yes
so
she was like that bothers you i'm like
yeah but i know this part this was part
of
i knew this about you when we got
married so it's not like i'm gonna marry
you now change like i can't
i felt like that was a really unfair
thing
for me to do if it bothered me so much
we shouldn't have got married
and that's the most mature stance
because quite often it's the opposite
like
we got married now it's time for you to
change into the person that i
aspired to marry yeah yeah and of course
that doesn't work now i think what
you're saying here and i love this is
it is possible to dislike certain
aspects of someone and still love the
whole person
and i think if we can if we can yeah
yeah if we can make that distinction
like
i'm going to dis there's certain things
ryan does i dislike certain things i do
that he dislikes
but but i can't even appreciate those
differences between us man i think
ultimately that's where you want to get
is is being able to respect and
appreciate those differences but
first the first step is tolerating right
right yeah you have to you have to get
toward respecting
like californians in general they're
very tolerant remember when we first
came together
everyone's so nice here the first time
we were in california yeah we're in
chipotle line and this lady turned
around she's like we are not nice we are
tolerant
i will say that's true for the last
couple months i've really made it
uh my point when i walk my dog or go
anywhere i
i contact and say hello to everybody
yeah because everybody's all masked and
it's like so hated now yes that for me
more than ever it's important to show
you i'm not afraid of you dude right so
hello
yeah and that's true because some people
just look at you like what the [ __ ]
they're not even a hello back
right they're not used to the friendly
part of it they're more tolerant they're
they're not gonna tell you to [ __ ] off
but they're not going to say hello
i grew up massachusetts in a small
little town
um in western mass and so
we were all friendly yeah right that was
not even an issue for us but
i think like saying hello to people on
the street
is it's so fascinating how
much people don't expect it they don't
expect any kind of interaction with
somebody they don't know
yeah they're almost jumping yeah like
yeah like what do you need something for
me
you know in new york i like doing it one
of my favorite games in new york
is to be overly friendly to strangers so
i was in an elevator with this dude it
was just me and him we were in a
high-rise
and we get in the elevator and you know
if it's just you and one of the person
in an elevator there's certain
etiquette rules yeah yeah like if he
stands in the back left
i stand in the back right right i did i
stood
middle shaded over a little to the left
so i was a little too close and i had my
headphones in but not
on because i wanted to hear and as soon
as we both get on he took back left and
i took
center left a little back and i just
heard him go
so we both hit our buttons and he was
like
40 and i was like 21.
and i'm sitting there and i'm just
pretending to sing
my song and i can just hear him just
heavy breathing in the bed just like
all right and my floor open this is all
pre-covered by the way
pre-covered i'll break over this one i
was still traveling and actually getting
into elevators with people
and the elevators open up and i hear him
go this is your floor man
and i go i'm on a ride up with you
and he just put his hand over the door
and he goes the [ __ ] you are this is
your vlog
but i like doing that stuff man a friend
julian
julian smith he uh he he likes to make
himself uncomfortable like
it just like stressed stretch his
comfort zone a bit and i think that's
one of also one of those keys to
satisfaction yeah so so i i think that
helps you
you know be comfortable in more
scenarios anytime he gets on an elevator
he just continues to face the back the
entire time
even if it's a full elevator so
everyone's facing the other way and he
just keep
because i mean you get on that way
everyone just turns around though right
i love you and he just doesn't turn
around and he just
stand there for 11.
i'm definitely i like that's great
feeling uncomfortable
i like making other people feel
uncomfortable
not in a gotcha way i don't like doing
that but i like the shared experience of
i love that feeling i mean this is
really how i live my life
i enjoy she's not watching us on youtube
who sure says i like weird [ __ ]
i do i like it so much if you ever start
a sentence hey do you want to see them
like just stop right there yes
yeah if i've never seen it before the
answer
i do want to see yes i want to see that
right i'm going to skip lottie's
question aaron i'm going to send you a
copy of our first book minimalism live a
meaningful life there's a relationship
chapter in there we talk about
the three different types of
relationships i won't go into detail
right now but if you like our podcast
you're like
the audiobook version of minimalism live
a meaningful life
or if you want the book book or the
ebook version we'll send you a copy of
those as well